so like I said in terms of mental health
I suppose is one of those things that
all of our health fluctuates you know at
different points in our lives and I
suppose exam time is a stressful time
for everyone in matter what I think for
anybody that you know does kind of
suffer with anxiety exams are likely to
be a kind of a really big trigger for
that and revision can be a very
difficult time sometimes as well because
sometimes you have to be sat at your
desk for long periods you might not be
interacting so much with friends or
doing all the kind of things that make
us feel well like you know hobbies or
sports or being outside and getting
fresh air all the things that do kind of
keep our well-being in a good place
are harder to keep up during the
revision period so it is a sort of time
when I think you know people can feel
like they're struggling a lot more and
obviously the pressure of the exams come
closer and closer as well as it's quite
scary do it so if people feel that they
are struggling with with anxiety or if
they feel like they are just being
cooped up and they're not working at
their best and they're not feeling at
their best what's the best thing that
they can do so I think it's very
difficult to tear yourself away from
revision when there's so much to do but
a good advice really is to try and if
you have a schedule and you have you
know timeframes mapped out when you want
to be studying try and include in that
schedule things like you know just
getting out and doing something that you
enjoy also include things like 10-minute
break every hour or so you're studying
because actually we only have so much
concentration anyway and past that point
you can't really memorize what you're
learn learning you're not really
focusing properly and actually that can
become really stressful in itself so
it's much better to have a 10-minute
break where you just completely take
yourself away from that situation so get
away from the computer away from your
desk try and maybe go for a brisk walk
will do something like active or meet a
friend so you can kind of take your mind
away as well
as your body from that stressful kind of
experience and then I suppose the next
level of severity if people feel like
that they are really struggling and you
know maybe it might be getting a bit too
much hell they might need to delay an
exam or you know that level of severity
what then should they do
they get in contact with work being it
might be getting good I did to get in
contact with well-being at that time
because we can think about whether
there's any support that that student
you know might be able to access that
might be helpful if a student wanted to
defer an exam what departments normally
ask for is a letter from the GP as
medical evidence whether typically would
say that they they feel that students
not in the best place to take the exam
currently and then I think each
department might have different
processes for how they go through that
and then I think the exams are normally
in August that have been deferred if a
student kind of thinks that they want to
want to do the exams and then it gets
really close to the time and they change
their mind I think they have to the best
thing to do is to get a GPS note on the
day of the exam that they need to go in
and file with the department and say
that they'd like to try and mitigate for
those exams which means they'll be able
to extend have an extension unto them
and it is possible to do that so it's
not a completely other question if the
problem is severe enough it's not
something to be taken lightly but if
people really feel like they're
struggling it's an option it's an option
yeah and I always encourage students to
talk to their department office or their
tutors about these things because like I
say there are different processes with
different departments so really good
just to get that information and just
get all the options and the kind of
processes involved so they know they
know what's work you know there's a lot
of different kind of emotional
difficulties that we would work with or
just if people are feeling a bit
stressed and feel like things are
difficult and then they're kind of
struggling to cope with the workload we
can work with all sorts of different
difficulties which is why we're with the
well-being center